[Musique]
un nouveau jour
se lève allez plus vite dépêchez-vous
bon on sent que les baisses tout de
suite ce polo on dirait une allumeuse
les enfants vont appeler Jimmy pour voir
s'il est debout
salut c'est maman je sais bonjour mon
garçon on vous laisse assurer que vous
étiez prêt pour vous
je crois en l'importance de la vertu je
crois en la loyauté l'amitié et
l'honneur que nos pères fondateurs nous
ont accordé mais c'est Maxime bébé c'est
comme ça qu'on fait
[Musique]
il répond pas à les gars
après une vaste enquête du département
de police toutes les parties ont conclué
estimé que l'université n'était pas
responsable je dois m'en aller faire
quelque chose d'important pour votre
famille
l'enquêteur de l'université a dit qu'il
avait trop bu
à cause de mon fils vous allez tout lui
dire sur votre fils c'est nature combien
d'enfants doivent mourir avant que
quelqu'un soit tenu responsable
il a pissé sur notre fils
[Musique]
vous vous foutez de ma gueule va te
faire [ __ ]
[Musique]